we talk a lot about the decentralization
of the currency prevents it from being
killed by government yeah do you think
that some of Wall Street's tactics can
kill Bitcoin well I think they can they
can reallocate it I put out a piece
yesterday the R and C words
reification and commingling excuse me
those are those are dirty words but that
is how Wall Street that makes its money
and what's fascinating this is kind of
an inside baseball you're a financial
guy you this is kind of an inside
baseball piece and I would have thought
that it wouldn't have gotten much much
play but it was already not even not
probably about 20 hours after putting it
up it's already had more than 6,000
views so a lot of people are wanting to
learn they understand that there's
something here and and and I don't mean
to be the bearer of the news some folks
have wanted to shoot the messenger but I
stood up the moment that ice came out
and announced it and said this is not
good for the price of Bitcoin and so and
you know look at what's happened since
then has had about a 20 percent
correction a lot of folks said a lot of
folks expected that this would be a huge
positive right and and and I'm so
sympathetic and and and feel the same
myself empathetic probably a better word
of about wanting to have the mainstream
acceptance that we've all been craving
this is validation that we have
something really special here and we're
no longer these sort of you know kids
off in the corner playing with their you
know fancy tech toy we're being taken
seriously and they're so much positive
to take away from that but it is a
double-edged sword and I do believe that
it has suppressed the price and the
reason is because now though the I mean
it's it's it's hard to say everything
that has suppressed the price but if you
look at it that day it's pretty clear
that that ice news actually it was a lot
of selling in Bitcoin that day and that
was the only news that particular day it
was a week ago Friday absolutely
what um if you're sitting there and
you're running a Wall Street bank today
right your diamond or whoever
and you see this asset class emerged
start to grow and you say I'm willing to
sacrifice my short-term profits for
long-term sustainability with this as a
you know mainstream asset class what do
you do right what would you do as the
head of that Wall Street bank well I
think you do what goldman does and i and
i i've multiple times written that
goldman was the one that among the banks
that was different
when when i and my colleagues at morgan
stanley we're going to meet ups
clandestinely on you know after hours
and on weekends and you know 2014 trying
to keep our heads down and not reveal to
the world that we who we worked for and
not to reveal our interest internally
either and our day job goldman folks
were the ones that didn't feel that
there was an acceptance a cultural
acceptance within goldman of accepting
curiosity and accepting wanting to
branch out and think outside the box and
the other investment banks all seemed to
ratchet that down and I just was
chatting with somebody who's a who's
working out at another investment bank
literally yesterday and he said you know
the compliance Department is still these
things are so risky and it's dark web
and no one you know you can't verify who
you know the counterparty on the other
side and very negative still so I think
a lot of the banks are still being you
know run by their compliance departments
in that regard but they're but but
they're missing out so if why am i
singing out Goldman Goldman is you know
they're they're putting together a
crypto trading desk lloyd blankfein was
was at the time the CEO one of the one
of the only CEOs one of the only Wall
Street Titans who actually came out and
and said positive things about Bitcoin
and said you know there was a time when
paper money was thought of looked at
askance as well and this was when Jamie
Dimon famously said he'd fire anyone and
then what you know when he said that I I
understood that because that's exactly
how I felt if I put popped my head up at
Morgan Stanley at the time you know and
and a lot of these banks have pushed out
their their crypto people and now
ironically they're scrambling to find
them absolutely it is an exciting time
that we're living through
what um what's the one area people
aren't talking about that you think they
should be well this Wall Street stuff
the Wall Street entry this is a big deal
and it's clear that that it's going to
take a lot of patient education of folks
to understand both on the Wall Street
side why it is such a big deal but you
got now the ten ton gorilla of market
infrastructure in the u.s. embracing
naked natively digital assets and I
think the fixed income market is going
to go in that direction pretty fast
because why would you bother to issue in
paper form anymore in global security
form it's just you know now that ice is
accepting natively digital assets game
changer for Wall Street I think a lot of
folks don't understand that and then on
the crypto side it's wait a minute Wall
Street really isn't your friend here
there are yes they're gonna bring
liquidity yes they're gonna bring
institutional investors in but they're
also going to create Bitcoin substitutes
off the chain and it's not as though you
know the the custodial exchanges someone
just today said hey mount GOx did that
absolutely we didn't own real bitcoins
if we owned bitcoins at Mount GOx we
owned an IOU from out Docs and a lot of
folks didn't understand that but I like
to repeat what Charlie Shrem has said
you have to lose money in Bitcoin before
you before you make it and I lost some
coins in mal Cox because that was the
place when I was buying that everybody
bought and I didn't fully understand
that but boy that was that was really
cheap tuition it was money well spent
that loss to me was money well spent
because I learned that lesson I didn't
own real Bitcoin and it wasn't until I
pulled my private keys off and ie pulled
my bitcoins off that I understood that I
finally owned real Bitcoin absolutely
it's so funny right for somebody who
learned about 2012 got into thirteen
thousand fourteen right for us to be
sitting here you know just a few years
later and to be reminding people that
wall sure he's not your friend yeah
right that probably wasn't something you
had to be saying in 2013 but the people
around the table but it's so fascinating
the knee-jerk reaction was oh my god
this is so positive and yes in some ways
but it's not universally positive and
and I just want to be very patient and
respectful because Allah
of really smart people just haven't gone
down that other besides rabbit hole yet
and if smart people on both sides it's
it's the Wall Street people saying what
I just getting into Bitcoin and it's the
crypto people saying what we can have
off chain fractionally reserved Bitcoin
substitutes so it's it's boy it's time
for a lot of folks to to go down the
other side's rabbit hole and really
learn well ethic to its a technologist
view right is it's math right and so you
can look at the numbers that you've got
there when they get exposed to what is
essentially financial engineering yeah
right it's something that they've just
never thought of absolutely and so it's
this you tell you know you mean to tell
me that people are actually gonna buy a
thing that represents Bitcoin but
they're not gonna buy a Bitcoin well and
interestingly when we start explaining
that and we see now that the Twitter's
gone absolutely nuts people are talking
to each other a lot of folks really
understand this and explain it to help
explain it to to peers it's people kind
of again realizing oh my god you mean
that's what crackin and bit mechs are
and okx are doing yeah they've been
doing it all along they've been they're
basically web 2.0 companies that create
a centralized layer application layer
and they record transactions to the
underlying chain but they're commingling
the bitcoins in an omnibus account any
time you have it you use a custodial
exchange or a custodian or you know you
store your coins at at coin base or
circle or bitpay
guess what you're doing you know you
have an IOU from them unless you're in
coinbase vault and it's the same thing
and so a lot of folks didn't really
realize that I know Andreas has been
trying to help people understand that
you don't own your private keys unless
you don't own your Bitcoin unless you
have your private keys he he can't
repeat that often enough is what I found
because even within the hardcore crypto
community there were a lot of folks who
didn't understand that nuance and so
again it's just patient respectful
education and this I snooze definitely
has caused a lot of folks to open up and
learn